foreign
Paul is in Springfield hey Paul welcome
to the Ramsey Show
hey how you guys doing today better than
we deserve what's up
um so I'd be honestly listen to a lot of
your podcasts about Building Wealth and
um this is something I've been working
on for
I'd say almost 10 years now I'm 31. good
for you
thank you
um I started investing heavily into real
estate because that's what my father did
and I saw the value in that of passive
income for retirement
um
I started a new job a couple years ago
and started making life-changing money
it's a lot more money so I started
getting um
a financial advisor to make sure I don't
spend the money stupidly or just start
investing in spreading my investments a
little bit more broadly and you know
obviously I want to keep investing in
things and keep growing this wealth
smartly but I was just kind of looking
for what your advice of you what you
think maybe the next best steps would be
well I think you're going to be fine uh
if you'll uh behave in a couple of areas
the reason I think you're going to be
fine is the reason most people don't
succeed with money is they just don't
bother to pay attention and you've been
paying close attention for a decade
which is very important and so I'm
guessing that you probably made some
really good strides so this wonderful
money you're making how much do you make
um well last year I made 540 000.
um this year I'm already I'm 100
commission based job
um so right now I'm at I think 300 000
so I'll call it I'm guessing I'm going
to make close to five again this year
um I have so in total I'm sorry I
thought you said 140 000 and then you
said 500 000 which is it
now and so I made I'm gonna make about
another 150 000 I think this year so I
think I'll be at 500 000 again for the
year
I think I'll be making 500k again this
year so last year you made 500 000 this
year you're gonna make five hundred
thousand dollars
probably yes give or take it's hard
that's fine I'm just trying to get a
journal I couldn't I misunderstood what
you said earlier okay good wonderful
congratulations that's just a Fab you're
right that's that's sick money it's
wonderful I love it for you you're
obviously doing some you're obviously
doing some good so here's what here's a
couple of rules I've discovered in 30
years of working with wealthy people
okay number one almost no one
statistically becomes a millionaire from
an inheritance so that's all just
mythology and bullcrap okay and we've
done the largest study of millionaires
ever done in North America 10 167 of
them 89 percent of them did not become
millionaires because of inherited money
so you're not that unusual as you become
a millionaire number two millionaires do
not do super fancy weird extremely risky
things and keep their money they usually
lose everything if they do so the
millionaires that we have studied are
fair really boring they put money in
things they understand and like for me I
buy growth stock type Mutual Funds
growth growth and income aggressive
growth International that kind of thing
and I buy real estate that I pay cash
for like you I grew up in a real estate
family mom and dad were in the business
and so I've Loved real estate I got my
real estate license when I turned 18
years old I love real estate I've got
buku's a real estate several hundred
million dollars worth but I pay cash for
it and I don't have any debt and all
cash flows like a bandit and I don't
have any of it that causes me super
stress because of that so
um you know but that's that's how I live
and my life is great because of that so
I would tell you to invest in things you
understand and you're comfortable with
obviously real estate is that
people who like real estate people who
like real estate often take on a whole
lot more debt than I think they should
right so yeah like I I haven't been
buying for cash per se and if I do buy
for cash it's because it's a it's a
foreclosure you know I'm gonna renovate
it and the goal is obviously to buy it
at the right price point and always over
invest and then and then refinance it
putting 20 down and using the the
passive income of the rents to pay
myself back or I have enough equity let
me stop you for a second there is no
passive income from rents if you've been
dealing with renters you've figured out
it ain't passive
well yeah it depends on how good you are
at screening no it's not passive I've
been doing it for 40 years dealing with
renters commercial or residential is not
passive that's Tick Tock mythology okay
the term no the real world is it's
active you're active you have to real
estate has the highest hassle factor of
just about any investment you do but it
has one of the higher returns so anyway
you called to ask what what I think you
should do I think you should use this
fabulous income to clear off all this
stupid debt you've got on this real
estate and you're going to have a much
higher trajectory in your wealth growth
long term short term it's going to slow
you down but long term when you have no
debt on this portfolio and the piece
that goes with that and this cash flow
that's going to go with it you're going
to buy a lot more real estate and pay
cash for it that's how I've got several
hundred million dollars worth I don't
have any rents that go to anything
except buying more stuff
I don't have any no payments yeah but
but you you hit on this earlier and I
think it's true when you get into the
real estate game majority of people they
have to go to the bank right like they
like when they're playing this game and
the majority of them arched in the
business 10 years later yeah because
they think it's passive it's not yeah
and they think there's no risk in the
debt and there's a lot of risk in that
debt yes and so it's worth going slow
the you know the the phrase you coined
of moving at the speed of cash and
everything you do including real estate
but that is a slower Pace than again
what you're going to see on your Tick
Tock or Instagram reels of people doing
real estate well when I when I was in my
20s I started buying real estate and I
was in a Real Estate Investors club that
followed all the crap like we do on Tick
Tock now all this nothing down real
estate or stay in leverage crap okay and
the guys that were in that club there
were several people that had millions of
dollars of net worth in that club a
hundred percent of them now 30 years
later are broke and out of the business
or or they paid off their debts and they
have paid for Real Estate there's three
of them that I know of are still
standing and they all paid it off and
became debt free the rest of them that
tried to continue to play The Leverage
game they got hammered in one of the
downturns or another and they're gone
they're out of business